Throw it into the sea.
Sheeta!
Hold onto that stone.
I'll trade her life for it.
Get up! No more hide and seek.
How delightful that it should end
in the throne room.
Come here!
The throne room?
This will be our grave.
What is a king
when his country lies ruined?
I won't give you the stone.
You'll die, trapped here with me.
There's no escape.
This is why Laputa died out.
There's a song in my valley...
Put down your roots in the soil
Live together with the wind
Pass the winter with the seeds
Sing in the spring with the birds
Your weapons may be powerful.
Your pitiful robots may be numerous.
But you can't survive
away from the earth.
Laputa will not die. It will rise again.